But for whatever reason,
that becomes more interesting because it's in our neighborhood.
Whereas if they find some distant star system and that it might have a planet
that's similar to Earth that doesn't seem as compelling for whatever weird
reason.
No.
Yeah,
I mean,
I think that the planets around Alpha Centauri,
Proxima Centauri,
which is the closest stars,
it seems like there are planets around those now.
And,
and that,
that was interesting because we could conceive of go in there.
I mean,
there was this idea,
you're Stephen Hawking actually,
and some others before he died,
had this idea called breakthrough Starshot,
which is the idea to send a little probe out to at the center,
the Alpha Centauri System.
And it,
and it,
I think in their view,
Yuri Milner as well,
the,
you know,
the entrepreneur wanting to do that and uh,
is I think he said something like a hundred years travel time or something with,
with,
uh,
with our current technology.
And they pointed out that,
you know,
we don't do that now.
We don't think a hundred years in the future.
But if you go back when people were building cathedrals,
people used to routinely start projects that would take a hundred years to bear
fruit.
And so we could imagine going there and that's,
that then becomes fascinating I think.
Cause then you've got a solar system,
another solar system that you could go and visit,
conceivably.
Conceivably.
Yeah.
I mean what kind of speed are we talking and how long would it take to get
there?
Well,
yeah,
I mean,
so it is,
I think the,
the idea was about a hundred years to get there.
So it's going four light years or so in a hundred years.
So whatever that,
so you would have to essentially do what they didn't like the Ridley Scott Alien
Film and put people into some sort of a,
Oh,
you're a robot probe.
It wouldn't be a crude pro wouldn't be possible for a crew.
Well it is,
but you don't have to freeze them.
Yeah.
That's always,
you know,
whenever you talk to engineers,
you had Ilan London years.
Yes.
Engineers always say,
you know,
physicists go,
well,
it's possible in principle.
So over to you,
you know,
you do it now,
there are no laws of physics.
It tells me you can't do it.
So we just do it.
But you know,
that's a weird relationships on the physics.
Physicists and engineers.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But,
but yeah,
in principle you're right.
If you can send a little robots facial there,
you can send a accrued spaceship.
I am of the opinion as time goes on and augmented and virtual reality gets
better and better that it doesn't really totally make sense unless we're talking
about colonizing someplace to send biological life to another planet.
If we can send some probe that doesn't have to worry about the,
you know,
the biology being affected by radiation or by the speed of travel or even buy
food,
we can send something out there and almost be there by virtue of,
you know,
goggles,
virtual reality goggles or something else.
Yeah.
You hear that in science at the moment.
Space Science,
we have this debate a lot actually because of course,
um,
space probes,
like curiosity that some Mars at the moment that's really cheap compared to
sending people to Mars.
And so quite often the scientists who wants to find out about the world's,
we'll say,
well,
we should spend it on robots.
We shouldn't spend it on people.
I think crudes face expiration is in,
in some ways,
I mean it's clearly true at the moment that humans can do more than robots.
So we can explore the place better for now.
Yeah.
But I think it has to be,
it's about something else.
I mean it's about it and he's not only,
it's about living and working off the planet,
which I think is quite persuasive argument.
Actually.
We've,
we've already industrialized near Earth orbit,
so it's already a multibillion dollar industry now.
He communication satellites and weather satellites,
gps,
whatever you,
we're already up there.
And so learning to live and work in space is I think a natural extension of our,
of our civilization.
Plus the fact that he taught.
So we,
Elon or Jeff basis,
they point out that the,
the amount of resources available just slightly above our heads is vast.
And so I remember I talked to Jeff Hayes,
US actually once,
and he,
he thinks really simply and he said,
you know,
for example,
in the asteroid belt,
there's enough metal,
I think to build a skyscraper psych.
What is it a something like 800 stories tall and cover the earth in it,
right?
If you want.
Now we don't want to dig that.
But his point was that the energy from the sun is all up there.
The results are up there.
So you could almost imagine trying to zone the earth residential at some point
in the future to protect the planets and do your heavy industry off the planet,
for example.
And these sound,
it sounds like science fiction,
except that now space x and blue origin,
those people have got reusable rockets.
So suddenly the economics become sensible.
So I think it,
I think,
I think expansion is good and I think we will expand and I think we will expand
outwards because there's not much room left on this planet to expand.
So I think we'll do so.
But he said that's a whole different idea.
It's,
it's not about gathering scientific information,
it's about a frontier and,
and all the benefits that come from operating as a civilization on the frontier,
which we've,
I've lost on the earth because there is no frontier left.
And so I like that idea that March and when you talk about Mars,
especially with Elan need right,
that that's the only place you can go.
So there,
there is no other planet we can go to other than miles that you can't go to
[inaudible] Saturn,
you can't go to mercury or Venus.
So if we want to go somewhere and expand our civilization,
it has to be Mars and everything's there that you need.
So with that,
that's a different thing saying you want to find out stuff,
you're right.
If we just want to find out stuff,
then you send robots.
But as far as expanding actual civilization and bring it to another place,
one of the things that freaked me out as people get depressed about living in
Seattle,
I mean you,
you're going to live on Mars.
I wouldn't,
I agree with you.
It's not renders thing is it's like the,
it been like the western front.
Yes.
Difference here when people cross the states.
Yeah.
Incredibly dangerous thing to do that when people cross the stage they still got
to Wyoming and beautiful places and Colorado and yeah,
but it was hard.
Yeah.
I wouldn't want it to do it.
But once you got there,
there's a river and this trout in the river and the,
the metals are green and mean.
I,
I agree with you,
right?
I mean I'm not going to go to that.
So there are vineyards and hotels and things,
but however
it is true that there are people he liked the challenge.
And what is true about Mars,
it's interesting actually because we know something about the history of miles
now,
quite a lot about the history of Mars and it's certainly clear that there was
water almost certainly oceans and rivers.
So,
and that water is almost certainly still there.
So I would say certainly still down where they have found large quantities of
ice now,
right?
Yeah.
So there's certainly ice,
the May even be pockets of liquid water below the surface somewhere.
So couple that with all the minerals and the resources that we know are there
and you have everything you need.
So that's the thing about Marcy's is quite nice relative to everywhere else
other than the earth.
You can't go to Venus,
you just melt.
It's what is it,
400 and something degrees and a 90 atmospheric pressure as I said,
so,
so Mars is quite nice.
Um,
but I wouldn't go there.
I agree with you because it was not gravity of Mars in relationship to third it
says,
what is it about a third,
I think third event,
right?
Yeah.
Something like that.
So it would still have a significant like weakening effect.
Like if you went to Mars and then somehow or another in the future that they
were able to get back to earth.
Yeah.
Your body would have a,
a real problem with that,
right?
It would.
But there,
there is,
there is still grabbed me.
It's a bit more than a third.
I can't quite remember.
But it's something like that.
But yeah,
so you,
there's still gravity.
So there's gravity,
there's some protection from the that you'd probably want to live in the caves
actually or something like that.
Cause the,
there's no magnetic field there.
So it's quite high radiation environment,
but not too bad.
I think it's further from the sun than we are.
It's not to the replaces our mouths.
There's a very deep critical Hallus,
which is a big impact basin.
And at the bottom,
the,
it's so deep you could fit Everest in it.
So you put Mount Everest in the summit of Everest wouldn't reach the rim of the
crater.
So it says something like,
I don't know what it is,
seven miles deep or some one six miles deep.
So you could go there and at the bottom the,
the atmospheric pressure is so high that you could just about have liquid water
on occasionally on the floor of that crater.
And it's quite warm.
Sometimes it can be 20 degrees.
Really?
Yeah,
that Celsius.
Um,
wow.
So,
so better than Keto right now.
Exactly the same as experiencing a serious coffee.
It's right.
Yeah.
So it can be warmer than Minnesota.
And,
uh,
so,
so there are places where it's not horrendous on Mars.
Uh,
you know,
so the Martian is kind of really stick in that sense.